ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
COPY GET ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THAT ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GROWTH HERTZBERG HILL.
WITH SO -- TADO.
JACKSON.
JONES.
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MITCHELL.
MONNING.
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
BY CASKEY.
WINNER [inaudible]
WILK.
WITH.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GAS BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LEADING PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY A CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE OBSERVE THE
PRESENTATION OF COLORS CONDUCTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT.
AND BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR GROW.
LET US BE CENTERED IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
GOD IF THE PAST PRESENT AND
FUTURE.
TODAY WE HONOR THOSEWHO RISKED
THEIR LIVES ON D. DAY. SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
BY REMEMBERING THE DEAD WHO GAVE
THEIR LIVES FOR OUR FREEDOM.
BY THANKING THOSE WHO SURVIVED
TO LIVE WITH THE GRIEF AND THE
LOS.
BY ACKNOWLEDGING THE DIVERSITY
OF GIFS CONTRIBUTED BY ALL OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
AND BY RESOLVING TO COMMIT OUR
LIVES TO PEACE TO JUSTICE AND TO
RIGHTS RELATIONSHIP.
GOD OF MERCY.
GRANT TO US THE COURAGE AND
FORTITUDE. TO PERSEVERE AND
BRINGING TO FRUITION IN OUR
LIFETIME.
OUR DEEPEST DESIRES FOR LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN
[inaudible]
COLOR GUARD.
PRESENT THE COLORS
.
SALUTE OUR NATION'S FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
[inaudible]
AND SEE [inaudible]
AND INDIVISIBLE.
COLOR GUARD RETIRE THE COLORS
[inaudible]
MOVING TO THE FLOOR CENTER
GROVER YOU PREPARE TO PRESENT AT
THE PROTEST ASK.
MISTER MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR GROW RELATIVE TO THE
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
DAY.
THE INVASION OF NORMANDY.
CENTER GROWTH.
THANK YOU MATTER MISTER
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AS C. R. FIFTY THREE S.
C. R. FIFTY THREE COMMEMORATES
JUNE SIXTH. TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN AS A SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ALLIED
INVASION OF NORMANDY BETTER
KNOWN AS D. DAY.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
OF SIGNING ON AS CO AUTHORS TO
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SPEAK AS A
UNIFIED VOICE IN HONORING THE
MEMBERS OF THE GREATEST
GENERATION.
ORGANIZED BY SUPREME ALLIED
COMMANDER IN LATER PRESIDENT
DWIGHT D. EISENHOWER THE JOINT
EFFORT OF BRITISH CANADIAN
AMERICAN FORCES.
THAT SOUGHT TO SEVER **** HOLD
OVER CONTINENTAL EUROPE AND
ULTIMATELY GIVE GERMAN FORCES
GET GERMAN FORCES OUT OF FRANCE.
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE UNTED STATES ARMED FORCES
FOUGHT BRAVELY TO TAKE THE
BEACHES OF NORMANDY ON D. DAY
WITH FIVE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
OF THE SOLDIERS ULTIMATELY.
PET PERISHING IN THIS EFFORT.
THESE INDIVIDUALS VALIANTLY FACE --
THE THREAT THAT ELEVATED GERMAN
MACHINE GUNS AND ARTILLERY UPON
THE HIT LANDING UPON THE LANDING.
AND IF THEY COULD SURVIVE THE
COUNTLESS MINDS IN THE WATER ON
OFF THE SHORES.
THEY REACH THE BEACH ONLY TO
FACE WHAT WAS AHEAD OF THEM.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN SOLDIERS
WERE WOUNDED FROM SHRAPNEL
WOUNDS THEY FACE PERMANENT
DISFIGUREMENT AND DISABILITY.
THOSE FEW WHO ESCAPED PHYSICAL
HARM FACE THE POSSIBILITY OF THE
MEN'S MENTAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
COMBAT CLICK COMPLICATIONS SUCH
AS PTSD IN THE YEARS FOLLOWING
THEIR SERVICE.
THANKS TO PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
SACRIFICE IT WAS UNDERGONE BY
THESE MEMBERS OF THE ARMED
FORCES AT NORMANDY WISH ONE
SHORTLY FOLLOWING THIS DAY.
THE VICTORY GAVE THE ALLIES AN
ESSENTIAL FOOD HOLDEN
CONTINENTAL EUROPE AND THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE **** REGIME.
CALIFORNIA'S PARTICIPATION ON D.
DAY LANDINGS IT HAS A GREATER
WAR EFFORT SIR TO BUY A MARKER
IN THE STATE'S CONTINUED
COMMITMENT BY THE UNITED STATES
ARMED FOR FOR FORCES IN
OPPOSITION TO FASCISM AROUND THE
WORLD.
I AM VERY VERY PROUD THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OWN NATIONAL GUARD
UNIT BAKERSFIELD BATTERY BE NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY A FIELD.
BATTALION PARTICIPATED IN THE
LANDINGS AND STAND AS THE STANDS
AS THE ONLY CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD UNIT TO HAVE RECEIVED THE
NORMANDY CAMPAIGN STREAMER WITH
A SOFT LANDING CREDIT.
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS -- SERVED IN WORLD
WAR TWO AND MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND VETERANS OF WORLD WAR
TWO CURRENTLY RESIDE IN THIS
STATE.
THIS IS THE MOST OF ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE NATION AND WE ALL
SHOULD BE VERY PROUD OF THAT.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I STAND HERE
IS THE FIRST FEMALE VETERAN TO
SERVE BOTH IN THE CITY ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE.
YET WITHOUT ALL THE WOMEN WHO
SERVED BEFORE ME IN WORLD WAR
TWO ANOTHER OF WARS I WOULD NOT
BE STANDING HERE.
OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND WOMEN
SERVED AT HOME AND ABROAD IN
THIS IN NON COMBAT ROLES.
EXCUSE ME AND RECOGNIZED IN
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT WAS A CALM
WHEN CONGRESS PASSED THE WOMEN'S
ARMED SERVICES INTEGRATION ACT.
EVERY YEAR WE LOSE MORE WORLD
WAR TWO VETERANS FROM THE
PASSING OF TIME BUT THEIR
STORIES LIVE ON IN WRITINGS AND
WORDS.
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
PERSEVERE AND PRESERVE THE
STORIES IN THE MEMORIES THAT WE
HAVE TODAY AN S. C. R.. FIFTY
THREE WE'LL HELP KEEP THAT
TRADITION ALIVE BY HONORING
THOSE WHO LEFT EVERYTHING BEHIND.
IS HE LANDED ON THE BEACHES SOME
OF THEM ALMOST JUST FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD LYING ABOUT THEIR AGE
SO THAT THEY COULD GO AND DEFEND
OUR COUNTRY.
AND AND JUST PROVIDES IS YOU
WAR EFFORT.
IN THESE BEACHES IN NORMANDY THE
SECURED THEIR PLACE AS THE
GREATEST GENERATION SO I ASKED
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW SENATOR
UMBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS LIMIT LET ME BEGIN
BY THANKING OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD CENTER GROWTH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ORGANIZING.
AND RECOGNIZING THE GREATEST
GENERATION -- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS.
IT'S SOMETIMES DIFFICULT AND
SOMETIMES WE GET CONFUSED.
AS TO WHAT A HERO IS.
WE TALK ABOUT SPORTS FIGURES AS
HEROES BUT TODAY ON THE SEVENTY
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY WHEN SO MANY
HEROES DEMONSTRATED.
SUCH UNCOMMON VALOR IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO RECOGNIZE
THOSE HEROES BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT'S ZERO NINE ELEVEN IN
MILITARY PARLANCE.
IT WAS ABOUT EXACTLY AT THIS
TIME THAT THE RANGERS.
TOOK POINT TO HOCK.
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT.
POINT TO HAWK WAS A IMPORTANT
PROMONTORY ON D. DAY OMAHA BEACH.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL JAMES RUDDER
WHO WAS IN COMMAND OF THE TWO
AREN'T TWENTY FIVE RANGERS ALL
VOLUNTEERS BY THE WAY.
WHO SCALED THE CLIFFS IT IS A
SKILL THE CLIPS THEY WATCHED AS
THEIR COMRADES CAME FALLING DOWN
BECAUSE THEY HAD BEEN SHOT AND
WOUNDED [inaudible]
AND YET.
EACH OF THEM STOOD AND WATCHED
NINETEEN YEAR OLDS AS OTHERS
CAME DOWN.
AND THEY THEN GRAB THE ROPE AND
SKILLED THEMSELVES AND ABOUT
THIS TIME THEY FINALLY DEFEATED
GERMANS BUT THEY WEREN'T
FINISHED.
BECAUSE FOR THE NEXT TWO DAYS
STRAIGHT.
THEY FACE THE COUNTER ATTACKS OF
THE GERMAN FORCES.
THE DOOR TWENTY FIVE IS STARTED
BY. FORTY EIGHT HOURS LATER THEY
WERE NINETY LEFT WHO COULD STILL
BEAR ARMS.
ON THAT DAY THERE WAS INDIVIDUAL
HEROISM.
THERE WAS HEROISM ON THE PART OF
ALL [inaudible]
INCLUDING.
THOSE WHO WERE.
OF DIFFERENT SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND SOME OTHERS INCLUDING THOSE
WHO WERE OF DIFFERENT RACES
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE.
OF DIFFERENT GENDER -- AS
SENATOR BREAUX POINTED OUT WOULD
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
FRENCH RESISTANCE.
WOMEN WERE ON THE BEACH IS MY
WIFE REMINDS ME JUST HOURS AFTER
THE FIRST LANDED.
ON D. DAY.
IN OUR COLLECTIVE ALLIANCE THAT
WAS FORM THAT DAY THAT BOND THAT
WAS.
FORGED IN BLOOD WITH THE
CANADIANS WITH THE FRENCH WITH
THE BRITS.
REMAINS TODAY AS AS PRESIDENT
REAGAN SAID ON THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY HE SAID THAT THE
ALLIANCE THAT WAS FORM THAT DAY
PRESERVES OUR PEACE AND
PROSPERITY. FOR EVER HE WAS
REFERRING TO NATO [inaudible]
IT IS.
APPROPRIATE THAT WE STOP IN WE
PAUSE TODAY.
THAT WE RECOGNIZE.
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN WHO GAVE SO
MUCH INCLUDING INCLUDING
[inaudible]
JAMES BELL.
JAMES BILL THE FATHER OF OUR OWN
SENATOR BILL WAS A PARATROOPER.
IN THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE.
WHO LANDED THE NIGHT BEFORE?
SO BY THIS TIME SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO HE HAD BEEN UP
PROBABLY FOR OVER TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND WOULD BE UP FOR AT
LEAST ANOTHER TWENTY FOUR HOURS
BEFORE HE COULD REST.
THOSE PARATROOPERS WERE TRYING
TO MEET THE FOLKS ON THE BEACH
THE FOLKS THE RANGERS WHO HAD A
SCALE POINT TO HOCK.
AND ALSO LATER ON THE WAR.
CAPTAIN JOHN C. MINING.
CAPTAIN JOHN C. MINING WHO ALSO
DEMONSTRATED UNCOMMON VALOR.
SO.
I THANK YOU AGAIN SENATOR GROW
FOR THIS IMPORTANT.
RESOLUTION I THANK YOU FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RECOGNITION.
AND I JOIN YOU IN ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I CENTER ON BURKE
CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TOUGH
FOR THOUGHTS COME RUSHING
THROUGH.
ON THIS COMMEMORATION OR
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF A INCREDIBLE
DAY IN HISTORY A GROWING UP.
IN MY HOME SINCE MY FATHER WHO
JUST RECENTLY PASSED WENT
THROUGH WORLD WAR TWO AND ****
OCCUPATION -- WE WOULD GROW UP
AND WE WOULD WE WOULDN'T GO TO
MOVIES TO SEE MOVIES WE GO TO
SEE THE LONGESTDAY YOUR TOWARD
TOWARD TORO OR PATTON THAT WAS.
MY DAD'S FOCUS SO I WON STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WATCH THE
LONGEST DAY IT'S IN. NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO EPIC ON THE INVASION
OF NORMANDY BEACH D. DAY -- SO
WHEN I WAS A TEENAGER.
MY FOLKS TOOK ME TO NORMANDY.
AND I WENT TO THE NORMANDY
AMERICAN CEMETERY.
WHICH IS FEATURED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE MOVIE SAVING
PRIVATE RYAN.
THERE IS A VERY.
EMOTIONAL OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO
SEE.
THE BEACH AND THE BUNKERS AND
THE CLIPS AND THE CEMETERY.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU IF YOU
EVER TRAVEL THERE TO PLEASE GO
WE DID NOT GO TO PARIS WHICH IS
WHERE I REALLY WANTED TO CALL.
AND THEY SAID YOU CAN DO THAT
WHEN YOU'RE ADULT.
YOU KNOW TODAY WERE FOCUSED HERE.
I WANT TO MENTION WALTER D. E.
LAYERS.
BOY IN A PARK RESIDENT.
BORN MAY.
SEVEN NINETEEN TWENTY ONE PASSED
AWAYRECENTLY PEPPERY.
TWENTY TWENTY FOURTEEN HE
RECEIVED THE MEDAL OF HONOR. FOR
HIS VALOR.
ON THE DAY AND THE INVASION OF
FRANCE IN NORMANDY -- EIGHT HE
WOULD LOSE HIS BROTHER ROLAND.
THEY WERE BOTH FIGHTING THE SAME
DAY.
HIS CITATION IS PROVIDED ON HIS
WIKIPEDIA PAGE AND SO.
I WON'T READ IT BUT WE'VE HAD IT
AT THE CIVIC CENTER FOR THE
ENTIRE TIME I WAS.
SERVING THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AND
IT IS JUST AN INCREDIBLE.
READ THE BEDS WALTER EHLERS
NEVER TOLD US THAT HE RECEIVED
THE MEDAL.
OF HONOR I'D DOUBLE DATED WITH
HIS DAUGHTER AT THE HIGH SCHOOL
PROM.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL IT THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY THAT HE
FINALLY STARTED TO SHARE.
HIS EXPERIENCES AND NOW HE'S
BEEN FEATURED IN NUMEROUS
DOCUMENTARIES SO IF YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO SEE ANY.
LOOK FOR WALTER KILLERS -- AT
HIS FUNERAL AT RIVERSIDE
NATIONAL.
CEMETERY -- GOVERNOR PETE WILSON
WAS.
THE ONE WHO GAVE THE CEREMONY
SPEECH.
THE LAST THING.
IS THAT TERM.
IT WOULD TAKE ANOTHER ELEVEN
MONTHS MISTER PRESIDENT.
AND TELL THE NETHERLANDS WAS
LIBERATED.
AND SO HALL AND CELEBRATES
LIBERATION DAY ON MAY FIVE
NINETEEN WHICH OCCURRED MAY.
FIVE NINETEEN FORTY FIVE SO I AM
SO GRATEFUL THAT THIS COUNTRY.
INTO THE ALLIES. FOR LIBERATING
THE NETHERLANDS BECAUSE WHO
KNOWS AT THE DIRECT BENEFICIARY
WHO KNOWS WORK MY FAMILY WOULD
BE.
WHERE I WOULD BE?
IF IT WERE NOT FOR THE WALL
DEALERS.
OF OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR STATE
THAT CHARGE THE BEACHES OF
NORMANDY RISKING LIFE AND LIMB.
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AGO TODAY SO
I AM.
HUMBLED TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT S.
C. R. FIFTY THREE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SIR MORLOCK CENTER
STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IN
COLLEAGUES FIRST OF ALL I WANT --
TO THINK -- OUR LEADER -- FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I WANT TO
THANK HER FOR HER SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY I WANT TO THANK MY VERY
DEAR FRIEND -- THE GENERAL FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY I WANT TO THANK
HIM FOR HIS SERVICE IN ALL OF
YOU THAT HAVE SERVED IN THE
MILITARY AND CERTAINLY -- YOUR
RELATIVES THAT HAVE SERVED IN
THE SERVICE PLEASE.
LET THEM KNOW HOW MUCH PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF AND I KNOW I SPEAK
FOR THE ENTIRE BODY APPRECIATES --
THERE DEFENDING OUR LIBERTIES
AND FREEDOMS.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU A
QUICK STORY.
I'M A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN MY
PARENTS GOT MARRIED VERY EARLY
MY MOM GOT MERRY TWO DAYS BEFORE
SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY MY DAD
AROUND.
TWENTY AND THEY MOVED -- TO THE
CHEVY HILLS AREA IN AN APARTMENT
ON HOME DRIVE -- I THINK MAYBE
AND CENTER ALLEN'S DISTRICT.
AND THEIR NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR WAS
AN ITALIAN COUPLE.
IAN JOSEPH PREEMIES.
AND THEY DEVELOPED A TREMENDOUS
FRIENDSHIP AND MARION JOE
DECIDED TO MOVE FROM LOS ANGELES
TO THIS NEW SUBURB OF LOS
ANGELES CALL ANAHEIM. FIVE MILES
FROM DISNEYLAND AND BOUGHT WHAT
WAS CALLED ANY CINDERELLA HOME.
A THREE BEDROOM HOUSE THOUSAND
FIFTY SQUARE FEET FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS BACK IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN
WELL MY PARENTS LOVED MERION
JOKE.
AND THEY MOVED. TO GO TO ANAHEIM
TO BE NEXT DOOR NEIGHBORS TO
THEM AND THAT'S WHERE I SPENT MY
CHILDHOOD IN ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA.
AND I HAD A VERY STRONG.
AFFECTION FOR JOING MERRY
ESPECIALLY JOE WE COMMONLY CALL
THEM.
UNCLE JOE AN AUNT MARY AND THEY
HAD. THREE KIDS JOE JUNIOR
RICHARD BERNICE NOW WHO LIVES UP
IN THE NAPA AREA AND MARIA --
BERNICE THE YOUNGEST OF THE
THREE BUT AS I WAS GROWING UP.
JOE NEVER TALKED ABOUT.
THE MILITARY I NEWS PATRIOTIC HE
ALWAYS FLEW THE FLAG ON MEMORIAL
DAY VETERANS DAY GOD BLESS YOU
[inaudible]
AND AS TIME WENT ON MY PARENTS
MOVED FROM [inaudible]
ANAHEIM TERROR.
AT A HOT SPRINGS AND MARY JO
FOLLOWED THIS KIND OF
UNBELIEVABLE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
LIKE FAMILY ALL OF OUR LIVES.
AND THEN AS A MARINE JOE WE'RE
GETTING OLDER.
THEY MOVED CLAREMONT TO BE
CLOSER TO THEIR KIDS
[inaudible]
AND I WAS MADE AWARE OF A STORE.
SO.
JOE WAS A WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN.
AND ABOUT EIGHT YEARS AGO.
A FRENCH CITIZEN WAS USING A
METAL DETECTOR.
ON THE BEACHES OF NORMANDY.
AND FOUND A DOG TAG.
IN A SAID JOSEPH BERNICE ON IT.
AND TURNED IT OVER TO THE FRENCH
GOVERNMENT.
THE FRENCH GOVERNMENT WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THEY KNEW WHO THIS
MISTER JOE PREMIES WAS.
ANYONE IS IF HE WAS STILL ALIVE.
AND WHAT WE LATER FOUND OUT WAS
THAT [inaudible]
JOE.
WAS ON THE BEACHES OF NORMANDY.
AND WAS BLOWN OUT [inaudible]
SURVIVE.
AND WENT TO A MILITARY HOSPITAL
IN GERMANY FOR A NUMBER OF
MONTHS.
AND THEN FLEW HOME. TO BE WITH
HIS WIFE.
AND IF THAT WASN'T ENOUGH.
HE RE ENLISTED BACK AND FOUGHT
IN THE BATTLE OF THE BULGE AFTER
ALMOST LOSE LIFE.
THE FRENCH GOVERNMENT TRACK HIM
DOWN.
AND SALUTE HIM.
AND HIS SON FIRST CLASS ON AIR
FRANCE [inaudible]
THE PARIS. TO RECOGNIZE HIM.
THEY GIVE HIM THE HIGHEST HONOR.
THAT A NON CITIZEN OF FRANCE
COULD EVER GET FOR HERE IS --
AND BRAVERY.
THIS SHOWS YOU THE KIND OF
DEDICATION.
THE FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
THAT EXISTED IN THE GREATEST
GENERATION OF ALL.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE D.
DAY INVASION WAS A TURNING POINT.
IN THE WORLD WAR TWO WAR
[inaudible]
WITHOUT IT.
THE CONTINENT OF EUROPE MAYBE
GERMAN SPEAKING TODAY AND A
POWER FOR WHICH WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
SO MY FRIENDS AS WE RECOGNIZE
THIS VERY IMPORTANT DAY -- I
WANT TO JUST PAY TRIBUTE TO ALL
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN.
THEY GAVE THEIR LIVES ON THE
BEACHES OF NORMANDY THERE WERE
MANY OF WHOM WERE SITTING DUCKS.
AS A FLOOD THAT BE CHAPTER.
THE SEAS WERE SO ROUGH COMING IN
FROM ENGLAND MANY OF THEM GOT
OFF THOSE TRANSPORTERS SICK FROM
JUST BEING SEASICK.
BOB DOLE WITHOUT THEIR HEROISM
WITHOUT THE INVASION -- WE WOULD
NOT I BELIEVE OF THE COMMENT AND
AND DEFEATING FASCISM AND
COMMUNISM -- AND THE DASTARDLY.
HEINOUS CRIMES OF ADOLF HITLER
THAT HAD A DEVASTATING EFFECT ON
MY FAMILY.
SO IN HONOR OF ALL THE MEN AND
WOMEN COURAGEOUSLY OF SERVED
ESPECIALLY THOSE.
THIS SERVED IN THE GREATEST
GENERATION I PROBABLY STAND AND
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF S. C. R..
FIFTY THREE AND MY IT MAY I ALSO
ADD IN HONOR.
OF MY UNCLE JOE
MAY HE REST IN PEACE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE LOCAL JOE.
TO THE SICK TO YOUR SERVICE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
AND ALLOWING US TO LIVE WITH THE
FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES WE
CHERISH TODAY GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE CENTER
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES I AM SO
HONORED TODAY.
IF EVER.
ALL OF US SHOULD BE HONORED TO
BE HERE REPRESENTING THIS GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS TODAY.
BECAUSE THE DAY WE COME TOGETHER
AS AMERICANS TO HONOR.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED IN
WORLD WAR TWO KNOWN AS THE
GREATEST GENERATION.
BUT I HAVE A PERSONAL TOUCH DAD
AND THAT IS THE FACT THAT.
OF MY COLLEAGUES -- FROM SANTA
ANA.
OF PHILLIP PARATROOPER WEARS HIS
WINGS AS I WEAR MINE.
AND I'M SO PROUD TO SHARE THAT
WITH YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
BUT IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM.
THERE'S A WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN --
SIR WOULD YOU PLEASE STAND UP.
ON HIS HAT HE HAS THE PATCH OF
THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE.
MY OLD OUTFIT
. TOO MANY WE MAY
CALL HIM A BAND OF BROTHERS.
AIR TO PURSUE SERVE WITH THE
EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE AND OF
COURSE THE HUNDRED AND FIRST.
BUT I'D LIKE TO TELL YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THAT I AM IN SUPPORT.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT ALL OF
US KNOW THAT.
THE INVASION AND EUROPE -- KNOWN
AS THE DAY.
WAS SO DETRIMENTAL. TO OUR
SUCCESS IN EUROPE.
BUT THE HEROISM THAT THESE MEN.
WHO -- IN THIS CASE I'VE GOT A
HIGHLIGHT THESE PARATROOPERS
BECAUSE OF A DEBT OF GRATITUDE
IS OWED TO THEM.
THE BAND OF BROTHERS WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT.
THE RANGERS WHO SCALE THE THE
MOUNTAINSIDE TO GET UP TO THE
TOP.
BUT LET ME SHARE WITH YOU.
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AGO. THIRTEEN
THOUSAND PARATROOPERS JUMPED.
INTO FRANCE BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
BUT I ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO TALK ABOUT THE AIRMEN IN
THOSE AIRPLANES.
THE ARMY AIR CORPS.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT.
OVER.
SIX THOUSAND THE EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE.
PARTICIPATED MANY MANY WERE
WOUNDED AND KILLED.
BUT LISTEN TO THIS A FLEET.
OF THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
AIRCRAFT THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
NINE C..
FORTY SEVEN DROP THESE
PARATROOPERS BEHIND THE LINES --
THAT ONE OH FIVE I'M SORRY AT
ONE FIFTY ONE IN THE MORNING
THAT STATE MERRY PLEASED WITH
THE EIGHTY SECOND.
BUT THE FACT IS THAT SO MANY OF
THESE PLANES WERE SHOT DOWN.
FORTY TWO AIRCRAFT WERE LOST.
IMAGINE LADIES IN GERMAN FORTY
TWO AIRCRAFT FILLED WITH
PARATROOPERS.
AND ARMY AIR CORPSMAN. FORTY TWO
THESE WERE WERE SHOT DOWN EVEN
BEFORE THE JUMP HAPPEN.
AND IT IS AMAZING WHAT THEY HAD
TO DO EVEN BEFORE THE JUMP
ITSELF.
THE EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE ALONG
WITH THE HUNDRED AND FIRST
AIRBORNE.
AS I SAID JUMP BEHIND ENEMY
LINES PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
DURING THOSE EARLY DAYS OF
FIGHTING.
AND STOP THE RESERVES FROM
COMING ACROSS IN STOPPING THE
INVASION.
THEN I STAND HERE'S A FELLOW
PARATROOPER GENERATIONS LATER.
THE SAY THANK YOU TO THE MEN WHO
SERVED OUR GREAT COUNTRY IN WAR
THESE WINGS.
AND ID LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR ACKNOWLEDGING THEM.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED IN
WORLD WAR.
TWO AND OCE AGAIN TO GAVE US
THE LIBERTIES AND FREEDOMS THAT
WE HAVE TODAY.
THAT IT IS ONLY FITTING THAT WE
SUPPORT.
ALL OF US WHO SERVED IN THE
MILITARY OF MEN AND WOMEN AND
THOSE WHO ARE SERVING IN UNIFORM
TODAY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE FACT
THAT ALL OF US CAME TOGETHER AT
A TIME.
WHEN THEY THOUGHT WE WERE GOING
TO BE DEFEATED?
AFTER DECEMBER SEVENTH NINETEEN
FORTY ONE BUT WE ROSE AS A
COUNTRY WE ROSE AS AMERICANS.
AND WE TOOK BACK.
WHAT THEY TRY TO TAKE FROM US
OUR FREEDOM OUR LIBERTIES AND SO
FOR THAT?
I RISE IN SUPPORT.
AND ACR FIFTY THREE AND I THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
CENTER NIELSEN.
WITH THANKS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD ARE REPUBLICAN
LEADER FOR BRINGING THIS TO US.
ON THIS HISTORIC DAY.
THAT A COUPLE OF INTERESTING
REFLECTIONS.
YOU MAY OF SOMETIMES HEARD ME
TALK ABOUT THE SPLENDID
LONELINESS OF LEADERSHIP.
THE PHENOMENA THAT WE PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCE.
BUT PROBABLY NOT A HEN HISTORY
MUCH MORE.
THE DWIGHT EISENHOWER
[inaudible]
WHO SAID [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WE'LL GO.
THOSE WORDS MUCH.
THIS INVASION THAT CHANGED.
WORLD HISTORY.
WITH THE BURDEN SOLELY ON HIM.
THE RESPONSIBILITY ACCEPTED IN A
NOTE THAT HE THEN HAD ALREADY
DRAFTED.
WHERE THAT INVASION? TO FAIL.
BUT OTHER EXPERIENCE.
IN TO MY ATTENTION AS I WAS
READING THE G. MALES OF MY
STEPFATHER AFTER HE PASSED AWAY
AT G. MAIL WAS A A LITTLE.
CARD.
TYPE THING THAT THE G. EYES
WOULD BE USED TO WRITE TO THE
FAMILIES OR THEIR LOVED ONES
HOME.
AND HE WROTE TO HIS MOTHER AND
ACTUALLY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE SERVER.
AS I'M RAMBLING THREE THESE
THINGS AND THEY WERE GENERALLY
VERY INNOCUOUS BECAUSE THEY WERE.
HEAVILY CENSORED.
HE'D SAY -- IN ALL OF DID THE
COW HAVE A CALF OR YOU KNOW
HOW'S THINGS WITH THE CORN CROP.
BUT THIS.
READ.
WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN?
WAITING FOR IS HAPPENING.
I THINK IT'S GOING WELL.
HOW TO THE FOLKS BACK HOME FEEL
ABOUT THIS?
AND I THOUGHT THAT STRANGE TILL
I LOOKED.
AT THE DATE.
THAT WAS THE DAY.
HE WAS IN THE HANDS ARMY AIR
CORPS.
WHAT WOULD BE CALLED TODAY?
AN AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLER.
WATCHING.
THOSE PLANES.
MAYBE EVEN SOME THAT CARRIED
THIS GENTLEMAN HERE WHO SERVED
IN THE EIGHTY SECOND OR THE
FATHERS OF AYE TWO COLLEAGUES
HERE TODAY.
WHO WERE PARATROOPERS?
HE WAS WATCHING THOSE PLANES AND
THEN HAD TO ACCOUNT FOR THOSE
WHO.
DID NOT COME BACK.
BUT THE UNDERSTATED WAY.
THAT HE PLACE THAT KNOWLEDGE TO
HIS MOTHER.
IS SO TYPICAL OF THAT GREATEST
GENERATION.
THEY WERE HEROES WHO.
TRIED TO AVOID.
THE GLORY IN THE BURDEN OF HAIR
WAS.
THEY WERE HUMBLE MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO DIDN'T GO ABOUT TELLING
THEIR STORIES?
SOMETHING THEIR CHESS.
THEY CAME HOME AND HELP BUILD
THIS NATION [inaudible]
END.
OTHER NATIONS EVEN THOSE THE DAY
AND SO CONTRIBUTED TO DEFEATING.
BUT THOSE MERE WORDS.
I THINK IT'S GOING WELL.
HOW TO THE FOLKS BACK HOME FEEL?
I CAN SAY TO MY STEP DAD MY
PRAYERS TODAY.
IT WENT WELL.
THANKS TO YOU AND THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS.
AND YES WE REMEMBER YOU.
GOD BLESS ALL OF THEM.
GOD BLESS AMERICA.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN CENTER
MORALE.
YES THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS ARE.
IT IS JUST GOOD TO BE HERE TODAY
TO BE ABLE.
HONOR THOSE FOLKS WHO SERVED IN
GAVE SO MUCH OUR COUNTRY -- MY
FATHER FOUGHT IN WORLD WAR TWO
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
WORLD HAND -- THE SOUTH PACIFIC
ONGARO CANNELLA GOT SHOT ONCE IT
HAD MALARIA TWICE HE THE STAIN
MOSQUITOES MORE THAN HE DID
BULLETS I LATER FOUND OUT -- BUT
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN I
ASKED MY SAID THAT WHAT WOULD
POSSESS YOU WHY WOULD YOU JUST
SIGN UP AND YOU KNOW RISK YOUR
LIFE LIKE THAT AND HE LOOKED AT
ME AND LIKE THAT WAS THE
STUPIDEST QUESTION A PERSON
COULD EVER ASK CEASES THAT'S
WHAT MEN.
DO WHO LOVE THEIR COUNTRY AND
WHO LOVE FREEDOM YOU KNOW SO.
THAT REALLY STUCK IN MY HEAD AND
SO I JUST WANT TO READ SOME A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS HAVE BEEN
SAID HERE TODAY BUT I LOVE.
THE FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY ON
RONALD REAGAN SPOKE AT NORMANDY
BEACH HE JUST SUM THAT UP --
ABOUT WHAT OUR SOLDIERS DID FOR
OUR COUNTRY AND WHY HE SAID THEY
STRENGTH THEY WERE STRICKEN BY
THEIR COURAGE HEARTENED BY THEIR
VALOR.
IN BORN BY THEIR MEMORY LET US
CONTINUE TO STAND FOR THE IDEAS
FOR WHICH THEY LIVED AND DIED
AND OF COURSE THOSE IDEAS.
ARE THE POLITICAL PRINCIPLES
CONTAIN OUR FOUNDING DOCUMENTS
THE CONSTITUTION A DECLARATION.
THE BILL OF RIGHTS IN THE GREAT
NORTHWEST ORDINANCE AND THOSE
ARE THE THINGS WHICH LIMITED
GOVERNMENT'S POWER IN.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY FOUGHT IN AS
LONG AS WE BELIEVE IN THOSE
THINGS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WIN WARS
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN SO I'M JUST
GRATEFUL.
FOR OUR SOLDIERS WHO FOUGHT
FORCE AND FOR CENTER GROVE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
TODAY AND MAY GOD BLESS OUR
COUNTRY.
THANK YOU SIR MORALE SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION CENTER GROVE
WOULD YOU CARE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
I'M HONORED FOR THE SACRIFICE
THE VETERANS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT HAVE -- FOUGHT FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
A I WAS GOING TO TALK ABOUT MY
FATHER TODAY.
AND AFTER HE CAME BACK AS A
MEDIC FROM OF WORLD WAR TWO AND
HE ACTUALLY HELPED -- RESCUE
INDIVIDUALS IN CONCENTRATION
CAMPS.
THAT LEFTSOMETHING ON HIS LIFE
IT WAS A GOOD MOVING FORWARD.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE
ARE MANY PEOPLE THAT IS SERVED
IN THAT WAR THAT CAME BACK TO
BUILD THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY NEVER QUIT AND THEY
MADE AMERICA REALLY WHAT IT IS
TODAY AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
CONSIDERED THE GREATEST
GENERATION.
SO ON THE SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF D. DAY I WOULD
JUST ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A
C. R..
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU CENTER
GREW UP WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BY BATES.
I BILL BY PORGES [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD.
BUY A COPY AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TADO.
BY JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LARK.
I'M A REAL.
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
BYE BYE COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
THIRD ROW YOU MAY INTRODUCE OUR
GAS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES OF TODAY I WITH US
TODAY ON THE SENATE FLOOR IS
MAJOR GENERAL MATTHEW BEAVERS
THE DEAD DE A DEPUTY ADJUTANT
GENERAL.
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT.
COLONEL DERREN BENDER A SERGEANT
FIRST CLASS REBEKAH WALKING
HOW'RE ALSO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MELODY MERIT MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
AND I ALSO WANT TO GIVE A
SPECIAL THANKS TO THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL COLOR GUARD -- THE
GUARD THE COLOR GUARD TO DO THE
PRESENTATION OF THE COLORS THIS
MORNING THANK YOU GUYS ALL FOR
BEING HERE.
BUT TODAY ALSO WITH US HE WAS
BRIEFLY INTRODUCED EARLIER I'M
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE YOU AND PRESENT TO YOU A
WORLD WAR TWO PARATROOPER.
SECOND LIEUTENANT JOHN H.
CANFIELD OF THE EIGHTY SECOND
ALL AMERICAN AIRBORNE AIRBORNE
DIVISION.
WHO JOIN THE FIGHT IN THE VERY
EARLY DAYS FOLLOWING THE D. DAY
INVASION PLEASE WELCOME
LIEUTENANT SECOND LIEUTENANT
JOHN CANFIELD
?
JOHN WAS BORN IN -- MERIDIAN
KENTUCKY -- SKEWS ME CONNECTICUT
ON OCTOBER NINTH NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE HE WAS THE FIFTH BORN OF
SEVEN BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
LIKE MANY AT THAT TIME HIM HIS
FAMILY LIVED AND PEACEFULLY AND
THEY STAYED VERY BUSY ON THEIR
DAIRY FARM.
THEY WERE OWNERS OF HISTORY FORM
IN BLOOMFIELD CONN NAY MILK COWS
EVERY MORNING AND EVERY NIGHT
THEY JUST WORK LONG HOURS ON THE
FARM.
FOLLOWING THE ATTACK ON PEARL
HARBOR AND HE SAID THAT DECEMBER
SEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY ONE JOHN
JOINED THE CONNECTICUT MILITIA.
THE JOHNS BROTHERS BILL AND JIM
HAD ALREADY BEEN SERVING ON
ACTIVE DUTY AT THE TIME HIS
PARENTS REFUSED TO ALLOW HIM TO
JOIN THE ARMY.
OVER THEIR WISHES WERE SOON OVER
RULED AFTER HE WAS DRAFTED ON
FEBRUARY SIXTH.
NINETEEN FORTY TWO JOHN WAS
ASSIGNED TO THE MEDICAL COR
TRAINING AT CAMP PICKETT GEORGIA
AFTER WHICH HE RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL SURGICAL TRAINING.
AND THEN HE WAS SENT TO WORK TO
THE AREN'T WITH YOUR FOR THE
ARMY HOSPITAL IN THOMASVILLE
GEORGIA.
THROUGH THE WORK THAT IN THE
OPERATING ROOM EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS FULFILLING MEDICAL WAR DUTY
WAS NOT HIS CUP OF TEA AND HE
DECIDED TO SET HIS SIGHTS ON
PARACHUTE TRAINING.
JOHN WAS DENIED ASSIGNMENT TO
PARACHUTE TRAINING BECAUSE HE
ENDS IN SO HE INSTEAD QUALIFY
FOR MEDICINE IN THE CIVIL
ENGINEERING AN ARMY SPECIALIZED
TRAINING PROGRAM.
IT WASN'T TOO LONG AFTER JOHN
WAS ASSIGNED TO THE EIGHTY
SEVENTH INTERNSHIP INFANTRY
DIVISION THAT HE BECAME A
DESIGNATED BROWNING AUTOMATIC
RIFLEMAN.
IT'S BAR FOR SHORT WHY BECAUSE
HE WAS THE LARGEST MEMBER OF HIS
TWELVE MAN SQUAD.
AND IF YOU'VE EVER SEEN A BAR DO
YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT ANY FRONT LINE
RIFLE THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT A
GUN THEY CAN TAKE OUT OF THREE
LINE.
HE WAS A PROUD INFANTRYMEN THE
MAN BUT HE NEVER STOP DREAMING
OF BEING A PARATROOPER AND IT
THIS TIME HE WAS CONFRONTED
WALKING DOWN THE STREET WITH A
POSTER BACK IN THE DAY THAT SAID
ARE YOU MAN ENOUGH. TO JUMP INTO
THE FIGHT.
IN THIS MAN ALTHOUGH IT WOULDN'T
COME OUT OF HIS MOUTH TODAY SAID
HALE YES.
SO WE AGAIN VOLUNTEERED FOR PEER
TO TREATING BUT THIS TIME THEY
SAID YES HIS ASSIGNMENT FORT
BENNING TO REPORT TO DUTY ON
JUNE SIXTH. NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
DDA.
THE WE DIDN'T SHIP OUT FOR
EUROPE FOR ANOTHER TEN WEEKS
MANY OF HIS CLASSMATES DID JUMP
IN THE INVASION OF SOUTHERN
FRANCE HE EVENTUALLY WAS SENT TO
EUROPE IN THE REPLACEMENT OF THE
EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE DIVISION.
IN FEBRUARY OF NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE AND WAS AGAIN DESIGNATED A
BAR MAN.
HE SERVED PROUDLY ALONGSIDE HIS
BROTHERS IN ARMS BUT WHEN THE
FIGHT EDED HIS SERVICE DID NOT
HE RECEIVED A COMBAT INFANTRY
BADGE AND A BRONZE STAR AND WAS
SOON TRANSFERRED TO THE FIVE OH
FOUR PARACHUTE INFANTRY.
REGIMENT WHERE HE SERVED AS ONE
OF THE FIRST AMERICANS IN BERLIN
TO GUARD THE MEETING OF THE BIG.
FOUR THIS WAS THE DAWN OF THE
COLD WAR.
EVEN AFTER RETURNING TO THE
STATES THE SERVICE CONTINUED HE
STUDIED CIVIL ENGINEERING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CONNECTICUT BECAME
A SECOND LIEUTENANT THROUGH THE
RESERVE OFFICER TRAINING CORPS
THE ROTC.
AT UCONN.
HE'S VERY ACTIVE IN VETERANS
FOREIGN WARS AT THE VFW AND
VETERANS AFFILIATED COUNSEL TO
SACRAMENTO IN THAT THIS WHICH IS
THE BACK HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
HE SERVED A LOT OF TIME IN THIS
CAPITAL DEFENDING AND CAN'T AND
AND THEM TESTIFYING BEFORE
VETERANS SERVICES COMMITTEES TO
MAKE SURE THAT VETERANS GOT WHAT
THEY NEEDED.
JOHN SERVICES AS A SPOKESPERSON
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA
VETERANS AFFAIRS ANY BECAME WELL
KNOWN LEADER IN VETERANS ISSUES
AT THE STATE CAPITOL.
A PARATROOPER AT HEART JOHN IS
NEVER STOP JUMPING IN AND OUT OF
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS AT HOME AND
ABROAD ALL FIVE OF HIS BROTHERS
AND AND ONE SISTER SERVED IN
WORLD WAR.
TWO AND THE KOREAN WAR ON BEHALF
OF A GRATEFUL NATION JOHN IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY
.
SO WE'RE GOING TO PRESENT A
RESOLUTION IN JUST A SECOND BUT
RIGHT NOW I'M IN ASK US CENTER
ROSS A SENATOR ARCHULETA IN
SENATOR MEMBER TO JOIN ME.
WE'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
COLLEAGUES IS CALLED THE
CLEANING.
AND WE HAD SPECIAL COINS MADE
FOR THE SPECIAL OCCASION AND
THERE ARE FOR PEOPLE THAT WILL
BE POINT ON THIS FLOOR --
OBVIOUSLY THE GENERAL THAT ARE
GENERAL WILL COINED THE
JOURNALISTS HERE IN IN THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ARE --
SPECIAL GAS.
THE COIN WAS DESIGNED WITH ALL
THE FLAGS OF THE COUNTRIES THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE D. DAY
INVASION.
ON ONE SIDE IN OPERATION
OVERLOAD IN ON THE OTHER SIDE IT
COMMEMORATES THE SEVENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF D. DAY.
SO -- JUST BEAR WITH US WHILE WE
DO THIS LITTLE QUEEN THIS QUEEN
CEREMONY THE GENTLEMAN.
THERE IS A MEMBER OF THE EIGHTY
SECOND AIRBORNE ON ROB THAT CAN
YOU [inaudible]
THIS POINT
.
HOW WE'RE GONNA JUST PRESENT
THIS RESOLUTION AND TO JOHN AND
THE GENERAL
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS JOINT FOR PHOTO
PLEASE DO SO AT THIS TIME
EDITOR
GROW.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AT
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE VERY SMALL
RECEPTION IN ROOM TWO ELEVEN
RIGHT OFF THE FLOOR IF YOU GUYS
WOULD LIKE TO GO AND SPEND SOME
TIME WITH THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE HERE AND WE HAVE -- SENIOR
READ A BREAD -- STUFF THAT YOU
GUYS ALL LIKE SO PLEASE JOIN US
INTO ELEVEN AFTER FLOOR GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER GROVE.
CENTER GALGIANI ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT AT THE PROTEST ASK
[inaudible]
SENATOR GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE THURSDAY JUNE SIXTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
TRANSFERS MYELITIS AWARENESS DAY
TRANSFERS MYELITIS IS A RARE
INFLAMMATORY DISEASE THAT CAUSES
INJURY TO THE SPINAL CORD.
SYMPTOMS OF TRANSVERSE MYELITIS
INCLUDE SEVERE NEUROLOGICAL PAIN
A LOSS OF SPINAL CORD FUNCTION
WITH RAPIDLY PROGRESSING MUSCLE
WEAKNESS OR PARALYSIS.
RECOVERY FROM THIS DISEASE IS
DIFFICULT AND REQUIRES MONTHS OF
ACUTE TREATMENT AND THERAPY.
DATA SUGGEST THAT ONLY ONE THIRD
OF PATIENTS DIAGNOSED WITH THIS
TRANSFERS MYELITIS WILL MAKE A
FULL RECOVERY.
ALTHOUGH AN ESTIMATED FOURTEEN
HUNDRED NEW CASES ARE DIAGNOSED
IN THE UNITED STATES EACH YEAR
TRANSFERS MYELITIS IS NOT WIDELY
RECOGNIZED AS BEING AS SERIOUS
LIFE ALTERING NEUROLOGICAL
DISORDER.
AS A RESULT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CALL FOR GREATER AWARENESS OF
THIS DISEASE IN ADDITION TO
FURTHER SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND
FUNDING TO HELP BENEFIT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE WITH THIS
CONDITION.
WITH ME TODAY TO RECEIVE THE
RESOLUTION ARE SANDER RAY AND
MICHAEL BACK NOW FROM THE
TRANSFERS MY LOAD MYELITIS
COALITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
AND ACKNOWLEDGING THEIR ADVOCACY
AND CALLING FOR INCREASED
RESEARCH AND IMPROVE TREATMENT
OF PATIENTS THANK YOU.
MANY CENTERS WHO LIKE TO JOIN
THE PHOTO IF YOU COULD --
PROCEED TO THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER
.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER
GALGIANI.
SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU PREFER ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT AT THE
PROTEST ASK YES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT.
YOUR MEMBERS -- AT AT PERHAPS
IT'S FITTING THAT WE TAKE A
MOMENT NOW TO MARK A A ÁI
DI<c.cyan> OTHER ANNIVERSARY -- WHEN</c>
IT IS YEAH CERTAINLY LESS
SIGNIFICANT THAN THAN THAT OF D.
DAY BUT THE NOT INSIGNIFICANT IN
OF ITSELF AND IT HAS TO DO WITH
A VERY SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP?
THAT THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HAS -- WITH WITH AUSTRIA
WHICH OF COURSE IS ON ANOTHER
SIDE OF THE CONFLICT THAT WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT IN WORLD WAR.
TWO IS OUT OF THE ASHES OF THAT
CONFLICT AT A DEEPFRIENDSHIP
GREW.
AUSTRIA WAS RIGHT ON THE THE
BORDER OF WITH THE IRON CURTAIN
DURING THE COLD WAR AND SERVED
AS A VERY IMPORTANT BEACON --
FOR DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM IN
THAT REGION AND ACTUALLY COURSE
BECAME A PLACE WHERE MANY PEOPLE
FLAT -- AND LAUGHED THE THE THE
OPPRESSION OF THE COMMUNIST BLOC
AND CAME OVER.
AND IT'S IN FACT DURING THE COLD
WAR THAT IN -- NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE SOMETHING SPECIAL HAPPENED
IN LOS ANGELES AND I WAS THE%
ESTABLISHMENT THE AUSTRIAN
CONSUL GENERAL.
OFFICE THAT THE CONSULATE.
THE AUSTRIAN CONSULATE IN LOS
ANGELES AND SO WE'RE TAKING A
MOMENT TODAY TO RECOGNIZE THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT THE CONSULATE WAS
ESTABLISHED AS A MENTION IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BY DR THOMAS.
CLASS STILL WHO WOULD GO ON TO
BECOME THE PRESIDENT OF AUSTRIA --
IT'S GROWN INTO A KEY HUB FOR
DEEPENING CIVIC AND LEGISLATIVE
RELATIONS AS WELL SUPPORTING THE
GROWTH OF ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
TIES BETWEEN AUSTRIA IN
CALIFORNIA NOW.
A MENTION THAT DOCTOR CLASS
STILL IS A SPECIAL PERSON IN ALL
OF THIS STORY HE WAS SOMEONE WHO
WAS KNOWN FOR BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER I AND AND AND YOU KNOW
THOSE.
I KNOW THAT HE WOULD KNOW HE
WOULD BE PROUD ANOTHER THE
CONSUL BUT HE FOUNDED AS
EXEMPLIFIED.
HIS VISION ALSO MENTION THAT
WHEN HE WENT ON TO BECOME
PRESENT HE WAS THE VERY FIRST
AUSTIN PRESIDENT TO VISIT THE
STATE OF ISRAEL AND HE EXPRESSED.
VERY DEEP SYMPATHY FOR THE
VICTIMS OF THE HOLOCAUST -- AND
AGAIN OF COURSE IS NOT LOST ON
ME THAT D. DAY WAS -- THE THE
YOU KNOW THE THE BEGINNING OF OF
THE GREAT EFFORT TO LIBERATE.
A EUROPE IN THE COURSE PUT AN
END TO THE THE THE THE THE THE
MADNESS OF OF THE OF THE
GENOCIDE.
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT THE
STRONG BY LITTLE TRADED INVESTOR
RELATIONSHIPS THAT BIND ARE TO
REGION'S AUSTRIAN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA RANKED AS ONE OF THE
TOP EXPORTING STATES THIS THE
AUSTRIA AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE ALL THE WAY
OUT OF THE WEST COAST.
SENATOR EIGHTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF GOODS THERE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO THE LARGEST
IMPORTER OF GOODS FROM AUSTRIAN
RELATION THE OTHER FORTY NINE
STATES WHICH MAKES SENSE --
HAVING IMPORTED ALMOST ONE POINT
THREE FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
GOODS IN -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
MEDICATION THIS JUBILEE PROVIDES
US WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
APPRECIATE MANY INDIVIDUALS OF
AUSTIN HERITAGE.
IN OUR STATE INCLUDING OF COURSE
OUR FORMER GOVERNOR ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER WHO HAVE MADE
FUNDAMENTAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE IN THE FILM INDUSTRY IN
ARCHITECTURE TECHNOLOGY MUSIC.
MODES OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT -- THE
HOLLYWOOD LEGENDS LIKE BILLY
WILDER AND FRITZ LANG I HAD A
LAMAR AUTO PREMINGER -- THE THE
FAMOUS ARCHITECTS RICHARD NEWTON
NEWT NATURE -- RUDOLPH SCHINDLER.
COMPOSER ARNOLD SCHOENBERG IN A
COURSE CELEBRITY CHEF LOOKED
WOLFGANG PUCK WHO I THINK WAS
JUST WERE AWARDED SOMETHING FROM
MICHELIN.
OF SIGNIFICANCE.
THE CONSULATE IS LED BY MY
FRIEND I MISTER ANDREAS LONER
WHO'S THE STEAM CONSUL GENERAL
OF THE REPUBLIC OF OUR STREETS
AT A A QUITE A DISTINGUISHED.
CAREER SERVICE IN THE FOREIGN
SERVICE FOR HIS NATION.
AN ACCOMPANYING HIM FROM THE
CONSULAR MISTER WALTER CORPS IN
THE AUSTRIAN TRADE COMMISSIONER
MISTER DENNIS FREDERICK'S
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO THE AUSTIN
CONSUL GENERAL ALSO MISS SIMONE
BLISS IS MINISTER.
OF CULTURAL AFFAIRS I ALSO WANT
TO MENTION -- SOME FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE FROM THE MAC CENTER WHICH
IS A VERY SPECIAL PLACE IT WAS
REDUCTION LORS HOME THAT HE
BUILT IN WEST HOLLYWOOD IF YOU
HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GO I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO GO IT'S A IT'S A VERY SPECIAL --
LANDMARK OF ARCHITECTURAL
HISTORY -- AND IT IS NOW BEEN
TURNED INTO A CENTER FOR ART AND
ARCHITECTURE I THAT IS OWNED BY
THE AUSTRIAN GOVERNMENT BUT IT'S
OPEN FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CALM AND LEARN.
ABOUT AND THEY HAVE WONDERFUL
EXHIBITS ALL YOUR TRAVELING
EXHIBITS CHANGING EXHIBITS ON ON
ARCHITECTURE.
AND I WAS JUST THERE RECENTLY
IT'S IN MY DISTRICT I I VERY
MUCH WELCOME YOU TO COME.
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY IN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND WE HAVE THE
DIRECTOR OF OF THE CENTER MISS
PURCELL A FRAZIER AND ALSO.
OTHER CURATOR AXLE -- SCHMITZ
BURGER WHO ARE HERE SO IT'S MY
GREAT HONOR TO PRESENT THE
AUSTRIAN CONSUL GENERAL AND OUR
FRIENDS TO THE MAX CENTER WITH
THE SENATE RESOLUTION IN
RECOGNITION OF ITS FIFTIETH
BIRTHDAY.
AND I ASK YOU TO TO JOIN ME IN
OFFERING A VERY WARM SENATE
WELCOME TO ALL OF COUNCIL
GENERAL'S GAS
.
THAT'S MY DOT
SENATOR JACKSON FOR PURPOSE OF
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE CHEST HONORED.
THE GREATEST GENERATION PEOPLE
WHO FOUGHT AND DIED COMMITTED TO
THE GENERATIONS TO FOLLOW.
AND IT IS MY HONOR AND PRIVILEGE
TO PRESENT TO YOU THE GENERATION
THAT FOLLOWS US -- AND REMINDS
ME AT LEAST EVERY DAY AND I
SUSPECT ALL OF US.
ON WHAT.
WE ARE HERE FOR WE ARE HERE FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION AND SO IT IS
MY DEEPEST HONOR.
PRIVILEGE ENJOY. TO INTRODUCE
AND YOU'LL NOTE WHO'S ALREADY
TAKEN MY CHAIR.
HER MOTHER MY DAUGHTER JENNY AND
MY GRANDDAUGHTER ELLERY ROSE WHO
ARE HERE FROM CHICAGO TO JOIN US
TODAY.
WELL WELCOME TO THE SENATE
CHAMBERS.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
ARCHULETA FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION [inaudible]
SENATOR [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY IN HONOR.
THE FUTURE OF OUR MILITARY.
THERE'S A YOUNG MAN IN THE HOUSE
WHO -- IS A CADET AT WEST POINT.
AND THESE ARE THE FUTURE LEADERS.
OF AMERICA.
AND I WAS HONORED TO SERVE -- IN
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HANDLE
UNITED STATES MILITARY ACADEMY
AT WEST POINT ON THAT BOARD.
BUT WE HAVE A VERY SPECIAL GUEST
TODAY AND I WANT TO GIVE THAT
HONOR OF THE INTRODUCTION TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA ANA --
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
IF YOU'D COME FOR JUST FOR A
SECOND THERE CADET -- THERE IS A
A FAMOUS QUOTE BY GEORGE
WASHINGTON AND GEORGE WASHINGTON
SAID.
THAT THE WILLINGNESS OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO SERVE N FUTURE
CONFLICTS IS DIRECTLY
PROPORTIONATE TO HOW WE
RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THOSE WHO
SERVED BEFORE.
SO HOW APPROPRIATE THAT YOU'RE
HERE TODAY THE CS RECOGNIZE THE
GREATEST GENERATION IN THOSE
THAT SIR BEFORE.
AND WITH THAT -- WITH THAT
RECOGNITION -- WE KNOW YOU'VE
GOT A GREAT LINEAGE YOU COME
FROM.
GREAT LINEAGE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SERVE US WELL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR YOUR
COURAGE YOUR INITIATIVE AND YOUR
DEDICATION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THIS IS THE
DEBT YOUR SUPPORT ON BE FROM THE
GREAT CITY OF PICO RIVERA MY
NEPHEW AND HE IS -- FINISHES
FIRST YEAR AT WEST POINT AND
HE'S HERE SHADOW IN ME FOR THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
BUT I AM SO HONORED THAT HE IS
JOINED MY TWO SONS AT WHAT POINT
GRADUATES IN ONE DAY HOPEFULLY
HE'LL JOIN THEM AS WEST POINT
GRADUATE BUT HE'S GOT THREE
YEARS AGO.
AND JOE SIMPLE LOBBY TO YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY THANK YOU -- BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU FOR
SERVING THIS GREAT COUNTRY AS A
FUTURE LEADER [inaudible]
YEAH.
CENTER PORTANTINO FOR PURPOSES
OF INTRODUCTION.
THERE PORTANTINO THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS --
I RISE TODAY FIRST A JUST A
SENATOR FORTY PRIVILEGE SHOP
PROUD THAT IN WORLD WAR TWO
ATTACKING AMERICANS WERE THE
LARGEST -- ETHNIC GROUP AND NOT
TO HONOR MY GOOD FRIEND KATHLEEN
GALGIANI AND MISTER HILL WHO ARE
ALSO ITALIAN AMERICANS I JUST
FEEL HONORED TO POINT THAT OUT --
BUT TODAY I RISE TO HIGHLIGHT --
WHERE ARE IN JUST A -- AS YOU
KNOW COLLEAGUES -- GUN VIOLENCE.
EVERY DAY IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
READING ABOUT ANOTHER TRAGEDY IN
OUR COUNTRY.
CERTAINLY OUR STATE HAS BEEN
AFFECTED BY GUN VIOLENCE AND
TOMORROW IS WHERE ARE IN JUST A
THIS JUNE HUNDREDS OF EVENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
FIFTY IN CALIFORNIA -- FROM
COMMUNITY SERVICE PROJECTS TO
MARCHES AND PICNICS THE BLOCK
PARTY THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
WILL PARTICIPATE AND WHERE ARE
INJURED VENTS NATIONWIDE AS THEY
STAND IN UNIFIED EFFORTS TO END
GUN VIOLENCE.
GUN VIOLENCE RAVAGES WAY TOO
MANY FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
ESPECIALLY IN OUR CITIES AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AS WELL AS MARGINALIZED GROUPS
OBVIOUSLY DEEPLY AFFECTS THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AS WELL AND
WE'RE DEDICATED IN CALIFORNIA --
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
COUNTRY SAFE FOR ALL CITIZENS TO
STEM THE TIDE OF GUN VIOLENCE SO
I HOPE WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND
SHARE THIS BELIEF AND CREATE.
A FUTURE FREE OF GUN VIOLENCE
AND SO TOMORROW PLEASE WHERE OUR
IMAGE AS YOU GO OUT INTO YOUR
COMMUNITIES IF THERE'S AN EVENT --
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
STAND TOGETHER I'M JUST WAY PAST
TIRED READING ABOUT PEOPLE SHOT
ON OUR STREETS SHOT IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND SHOT.
JUST.
JUST HORRIBLE -- AND WITH ME
TODAY UP IN THE GALLERY IF WE
COULD GIVE A ROUSING -- SENATE
WELCOME TO MOMS DEMAND ACTION --
ARE JOINING US IN THE CHAMBER.
AND THESE MOMS ARE.
MARCHING THROUGH CALIFORNIA. TO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER SO
THANK YOU AND PLEASE WEAR ORANGE
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER
PORTANTINO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JUNE THIRD THROUGH
THE SIX TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
THERE BRADFORD THANK YOU WAS
PRESENT AT THE REQUEST AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AB. FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN ONE MORE TIME SENATOR
CENTER RIGHT BRADFORD.
I TO REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
RESCUE REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR A. B..
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
I'M FORTY TWO YES SENATOR
JACKSON'S Q. A MISS PRESS AND I
REQUEST THE FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE AB.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN BE REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT
[inaudible]
COOLEY NOTED [inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
PRESIDENT TO MOVE TO REMOVE ITEM
THIRTY TWO A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE THE REQUESTED THE OFFER.
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
RIGHT WITH THAT WE'RE MOVING ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF
CONSIDERATION THE DAILY FILE.
A SECOND READING FILE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY THREE
WITH THE MOMENTS A TWENTY SEVEN
WITH A MOMENT'S ASSEMBLY BILL
212-153-31820 TWO THANK YOU SO
MUCH MOVING ON TO THE
CONSECUTIVE SO CONSECUTIVE -- WE
JUST REMOVED ITEM FORTY SO
SHOULD BE ITEMS FORTY ONE
THROUGH.
FORTY FIVE ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO
MOVE ANYTHING UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CENTER HUESO [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BUT KP A NICHE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY
THREE FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY NINE SEVENTY THREE AND THE
SOME CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
OUT OKAY WE CAN WITHOUT
OBJECTION -- ICE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO SPECIAL CONSENT.
CALENDAR IN CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS.
ADOPTED MOVING ARE MOVING NOW TO
COMMITTEE ASSIGNED COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
NO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
[inaudible]
NO GREAT [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
HELLO MR MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS PRESENT
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS FOLLOWING A
SESSION.
THANK YOU SIR.
NOW WITHOUT SEEING NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK
IS CLEAR THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT -- WE WILL BE BACK IN
SESSION ON MONDAY JUNE TENTH AT
TWO PM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT-MOTION WILL BE PASSED I WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE HERE
MONDAY AT TWO PM MEMBERS HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND